november is alzheimer's disease
awareness month and family caregiver
month
the key memory alive organization is
giving us a month of memories
and a fabulous way to give back rocky is
live at del monaco steakhouse inside the
venetian to tell us how we can
dine at a distance for a great cause hey
rocky
hey you guys yeah of course this is a
wonderful cause and specifically in
nevada i want to read you
a fact right now so according to the
alzheimer's association nevada has the
third fastest growing dementia
population
in the country so obviously this is
really important to our community
specifically right jody
exactly and between now and 2025
medicaid is going to go up 49 bringing
the total number from 185 million
to 275 million so it's so important
to bring community awareness to this
cause and to support the cleveland
clinic lou rouevo center because we have
wonderful family caregiver
support programs and educations
definitely and the keep memory alive
foundation you guys
are obviously keeping memories alive by
making more memories right so how can we
do that with you guys as well
it's wonderful so um november is
alzheimer's awareness month and during
november we have wonderful
initiatives but one of the initiatives i
wanted to bring up now was dining at a
distance
and dining at a distance you can go
online keepmemoryalive.org
and purchase a voucher and then choose
from a prefix
menu item or pick it up and wow
so that's going on you know the month of
november it's started already so please
go on to keepmemoryalive.org
and purchase that voucher and that helps
support all the caregiver and family
support programs
at the ruvo center that is amazing so
you have to tell us since you are with
keep memory alive
you know what are you seeing right now
how are families you know
how are families spending their time and
reacting to this time as we're in
quarantine and
trying to stay well sure well you know
with dementia in alzheimer's you have a
lot of isolation and people
feel very isolated at home so one thing
we've noticed is our virtual
platform programs has really increased
in attendance because it gives the
caregiver the family member that's going
through the disease
to be able to participate in wonderful
like art and mind programs that we have
we have lunch and learns
wonderful caregiver support programs and
this is open to anybody so you go online
and again
keepmemorylive.org and look under
caregiver family support programs that's
awesome well look at all this food you
guys this is something you can enjoy
while giving back to a great cause
coming up in the four o'clock we're
going to tell you more about the other
initiatives
this month for month of memories so stay
tuned thank you
rocky we appreciate it we'll check back
in with you later on and ron paul wanted
lance to pan out because he's so hungry
just wanted to dive in there and eat
that food lots of good food
delicious good food for a great cause
and now let's send it to nate